to me at a very surface level analysis
it doesn't look legit it looks targeted
it looks political
but doesn't that make you worry that
come election time which is literally
next year things are going to get very
ugly Joe may be trying to hold on to
keep Hunter out of jail you know to
maintain his his pardon ability but
without pardoning him too soon because
then it affects the election it it
screams two sides trying to stay on a
jail I mean honestly the only way I
think Trump stays out of jail is by
winning the election in a way I think he
may have brought it on himself his very
first statement about Hillary Clinton
should be in jail I I feel like when he
started talking real jail then politics
changed and they said if you're going to
talk real jail for us we're actually
going to put you in jail
and it looks like that's what's
happening
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People our terrific returning guest
today is the creator of Dilbert and a
prominent political and cultural
commentator today Scott Adams welcome
back to the show
thanks for having me it's a pleasure oh
it's great to have you back a lot has
been happened since we last spoke the
last time we had you on the show uh you
were predicting the outcome of the 2020
election with us uh you did say at the
time uh that Donald Trump would win if
nothing changed and then a pandemic and
an economic crisis happened
so your provider was well crafted we
wanted to have you on uh back on the
show for a bunch of reasons one of them
is obviously there is a big election
coming up and we wanted to get a sense
of what's happening over there what's
your take on uh the indictment of Donald
Trump and the different candidates
contesting the field so let's open up
with that what do you make of everything
that's going on so far
well it looks to most people to be
completely political
um I think if you have four indictments
and all four of them look a little
sketchy to at least half of the country
that it's hard to imagine that this is
anything but political and if you look
at all the you know the surrounding
things that have led up to it from
everything from Russia collusion to the
the laptop hoax to the Fine people hoax
you see a pattern of really targeting
one person in a huge coordinated way
and I've said that what are the
difference between the the Democrats and
the Republicans this is just
observational is that both sides have a
lot of BS you know there's a lot of
stuff that's not true that people
believe but generally on the Republican
side it seems to Bubble Up from
individuals so it'll be somebody who has
a claim and other people latch onto it
and then maybe someday somebody
leadership will say that Clayton and
then it becomes a thing but on the
Democrat side it appears that they do
organized
multi-organizational Ops you know the
the laptop the laptop uh was Russian
disinformation that involved a number of
entities that that wasn't a few
individuals there were people in
leadership who coordinated across the um
the government the Intel agencies and
the media and to me that looks like a
RICO case you know the American law that
would treat a criminal Enterprise as
operating in in some kind of coordinated
ongoing criminal fashion so that looks
really different
um and that's what it appears to be from
a voter's perspective who's you know
watching the whole field
and Scott one of the questions I'm
always curious to disentangle is when
you say it looks political are you
saying that Donald Trump is innocent of
all the things of which he's being
accused or not guilty at least or are
you saying that his behavior is akin to
Hillary Clinton's server let's say or
Joe Biden's documents or various other
things that are not prosecuted yet on
Donald Trump's case they will go after
every single little thing every time he
put a foot wrong so is it that he's not
guilty or is it that the prosecution is
actually persecution I guess is what I'm
asking well you know I think you get
lost in the details if you start
comparing you know the Hillary situation
to you know Trump or any other uh I
think it's a valid it's a valid
observation that they're not being
treated the same but I think you could
take it up a level and say it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter if you did
those things it doesn't matter how bad
they were because the reason they're
going after doesn't seem to be related
to what he did and you you can make that
judgment based on how other people are
treated in other situations but if you
look at the you know as I said the
complex the entirety of it it appears
that there are ongoing organized Ops to
get rid of one person for reasons that
are not entirely clear but it must be
probably self-preservation or profit or
something but it doesn't look like we're
involved in anything that classically
would look like a democratic process it
looks like people in power running
operations almost like it was an
intelligence based entity running all
thing I don't know that that's the case
it just looks like it is and
um I just don't think the details matter
but the the one that really
puts it in Focus the best is the January
6th stuff if you if you had never heard
any hoaxes being perpetrated against
Trump you might say oh that sounds
reasonable that he was trying to
overthrow the country or something but
as soon as you start asking any
questions about that such as all right
connect the connect the dots let's say
Trump was trying to overthrow the
country and he got some some people to
say that they were the fake electors but
they were the real ones you know let's
say they were claiming they were real
ones
how would that go would everybody else
in the country just say well you got us
we didn't see you doing this fake
collector thing let's just go on you're
the president now of course not it would
go to the Supreme Court like everything
and then we'd probably get some kind of
result we could live with or let's say
that the the protests continued what was
going to happen were the people who
didn't have weapons who were trespassing
in one building was that enough to
conquer the country
you know give me give me some details
about how trespassing turns into control
of the nuclear Triad and the fact that
half of the public believes that that
was an Insurrection or it could have
been one or that under any circumstance
that could have turned into something
that would have changed the the
leadership of the country by itself
there's no reasonable way that could
have happened but yet half the country
has been convinced they did half the
country believe the fine people hoax
that half the country believes that the
president suggested drinking a
disinfectant none of those things
happened the laptop we know was not
Russian disinformation
Etc so the the January 6 slash
Insurrection quote quote unquote was
just an OP not the event but the way it
was treated and the way they impeached
him was just an OP to make something
that was a legitimate protest meaning
people had legitimate complaints I don't
know about the reality of it but they
had legitimate complaints and they acted
out and some some got out of control and
some were violent but when you see when
you see how thoroughly half of the
country has been brainwashed into
thinking that was something you would
call a coup
or an insurrection
when it seems far more obvious that the
way Trump has been treated in you know
before the first election and all the
way through seems like more of an
Insurrection or ongoing coup attempt
against somebody who was elected legally
once and his claim is that maybe he got
elected twice but I'll leave that to
earthquake I I don't have evidence of
anything like that Scott to me I find
this whole Trump situation incredibly
worrying because Trump I think most
people would realize is a symptom of the
ills of America he's not the problem
itself
but what they're effectively doing as
far as I can see is their antagonizing
his voter base and they're doing
absolutely nothing in order in order to
bring about any type of Harmony this is
incredibly dangerous isn't it
yeah you know
um of course the the big conversation in
America is about the division you know
the Democrats and the Republicans or the
race division the gender division
Etc but here here's a reframe
um from my book
reframe your brain
um
you probably didn't even notice that
here's a here's another way to think of
all this division
if you if I walk outside and run into a
black American
are we going to have a problem never in
my whole life I've never had a racial
problem with an actual person standing
in front of me but then I go online and
everything's you know racial racial
racial and you know I think I'm sending
off my good tweet or X post and I think
ah got a little dopamine hips if I'm in
person I can't get a dopa being hit by
acting like the the racial division is
the main thing I want to talk about in
fact I would avoid it at all costs
Politics as well so in person you're
managing your cortisol levels you don't
want to get into conflict because your
cortisol will go up you'll feel anxious
it just all it's all negative as soon as
you get online the cortisol risk goes
away because there's nobody there in
person if you send off a good gotcha you
know kind of a post you're like ah
dopamine so we have a dopamine machine
through the the social media that's
driving division so we can get dopamine
hits and dopamine is almost as
predictable as money you know they say
follow the money well
money is one of the ways you get
dopamine so if you just look at the
dopamine of course we're acting like
we're divided but it's not real I mean
that too is is somehow a part of the
design of the system I don't know how
much is intentional but it's not a real
thing in the real world as soon as you
walk out the door it doesn't exist
Scott
I would ask you this you're watching
what is happening with Trump now I'm in
agreement with you to me at a very
surface level analysis it doesn't look
legit it looks targeted it looks
political
but doesn't that make you worry that
come election time which is literally
next year things are going to get very
ugly
yeah so here's the warning that I try to
give everybody it does look like there
might be some attempt by the Democrats
or whoever's running things to get the
Republicans to overreact because if they
can get another January 6 kind of
reaction some kind of a mass protest
then once again they get to say well
look at all those white supremacists
insurrectionists trumps the devil you
know he's the one who calls it all so
they can just recreate the same op and
people are already primed to to fill in
that frame with with whatever new
confirmation bias they give so I don't
want to say if this happens there will
be you know violin acts because then I
would be part of you know maybe
encouraging people to think in those
ways and I don't I don't encourage any
violence instead I'd rather say that
we're creating a situation which has no
predictability
in other words if Trump were to lose
again let's let's say a worst case
scenario he runs against Joe Biden which
looks to be like that's going to happen
at least some people imagine
and Biden continues to degrade until
it's just obvious there's nothing there
at this point but imagine if Trump lost
under that that situation do you think
that his supporters would say that was a
fair election they just preferred the
guy with no cognitive ability over Trump
would you say that or do you think
they're going to say well there's proof
first time we weren't positive we were
suspicious but this second time he was
running against an empty suit
if he loses then
that's unpredictable now if I were to
advise people how to act if they were
sure an election had been let's say not
completely Fair definitely wouldn't be
with guns definitely wouldn't be with
violence but
um the same thing I would recommend if
Trump spends a day in jail
everybody should show up
everybody
like you should just walk off your job
and just show up get a couple of million
people standing around the jail and you
don't need any violence right at some
point
um peaceful energy can be as big as
violence and more productive so I think
something massive in terms of physical
action short of violence would be the
right play but I don't know exactly what
that looks like so there are not a lot
of options if we reach that point
yeah I know I agree I don't think
there's a lot of options do you think
that this is damaged Trump's chance I
think he's going to win I think he's
going to win the nomination
I'm but do you think that's actually
damaged his chances of winning the
election as a whole the fact that he's
got all these indictments against him
I think there are only two things that
could stop him well maybe three one
would be a rigged election that could
stop him two would be if he keeps
talking because you know things he says
they take out of context so if he says a
new thing they can take in a context you
know they've got a whole new weapon so
if he if he plays it cool and doesn't
say much more than the things he always
says he should just Coast into the into
the uh presidency now the the other
thing which has no scientific basis
maybe is the idea Elon Musk says this
and I like to say it as well the reality
tends to be biased toward the most
entertaining outcome not for the people
in the story it might be all bad for
them but from the observer's point of
view the most entertaining outcome and
by far the most energy entertaining
outcome if you know a standard three-act
movie play at the end of the third act
the the hero of the movie is in such a
bad situation you can't even imagine how
they would get out and somehow they do
here's what the perfect movie would look
like I don't predict it I'm just telling
you if that way of predicting works this
is what it would look like
uh Trump is either you know on the risk
of going to jail or even maybe he spends
a day in jail and somehow at about the
same time as the election is nearing
proof of election irregularity in 2020
is provided like it actually comes out
of nowhere I don't see any right let me
be clear I'm not aware of any election
irregularity that I think is credible
but that would be the perfect movie if
the thing that most people have
discounted at this point I don't think
there's going to be any Smoking Gun
we're not going to fight with anything
if there is anything uh it would be the
perfect movie to sweep him into office
based on finding out that was true and
then to clean house and take care of as
much business as he needs to now at this
point I think it's an existential risk
to Democrat leadership I think they're
looking at jail
they're they're not looking at just
losing an election and I think they know
that because once you say you know Trump
we're going to put you in actual jail
and we're trying as hard as we can to do
it the gloves are off there's nothing to
keep Trump from saying all right if I
can find any ridiculous reason that you
broke a law we're not going to play the
old rules where if it isn't a good
reason you don't pursue it because
that's not the way they play it so in a
way I think he may have brought it on
himself his very first statement about
uh Hillary Clinton should be in jail I I
feel like when he started talking real
jail then politics changed and they said
if you're going to talk real jail for us
we're actually going to put you in jail
and it looks like that's what's
happening so if he wins
in this third act you know miraculous
you know don't expect it but who knows
you know find something about the
election to the sticks
then a lot of people I thank you try to
jail and I'd be in favor of that
actually
well if you think about your scenarios
in part three I mean uh him winning as a
result of election interference in 2020
being revealed if there is any I think
is unlikely given what we've seen in
terms of you know the hunter Biden
laptop that got suppressed uh a few days
before the election so even if there is
anything uh which as you say there's no
evidence that we have that there is I
don't know that that would get there but
what I'm curious to ask you Scott is a
bigger picture question which is what
you've described is actually a very sad
downward spiral for your country
um and the question I suppose is this I
am old enough to remember when uh Al
Gore lost their election to George Bush
it was very close
the Democrats fought but eventually
conceded that he'd lost and George Bush
would became president uh when Hillary
lost to Donald Trump in 2016
she took a long time and in fact I don't
know if she ever fully accepted that she
lost she called him an illegitimate
president I believe he knows he's an
illegitimate president he knows he knows
that there were a bunch of different
reasons why the election turned out the
way it did and I'd take responsibility
for those parts of it that I should and
so I know that he knows that this wasn't
on the level I don't know that we'll
ever know everything that happened but
clearly we know a lot and are learning
more every day and history will probably
sort it all out so of course he's
obsessed with me and I believe that it's
a guilty conscience in so much as he has
a conscience that was okay she wasn't
you know kicked off Twitter and you know
whatever
and then Donald Trump questions the
results of the 2020 election I'm gonna
make a prediction I'm not normally in
the predictions business but I'm going
to say whoever loses the election in
2024 is going to claim it was
illegitimate one way or another and
that's not a hard prediction to make
let's be clear right if it's close
especially so
where does that leave America and how do
how does a society that has become I
mean you say the division is online and
I agree with you but online filters
through to real life and people who are
online then go out into the streets how
does a country like the United States
handle this sort of political Rancor and
disagreement and dispute about the very
basic outcomes of your elections
well let me give you the uh the old guy
perspective I finally reached the age
where I can say ah let me let me tell
you just to be when I was a kid right so
I got to you know live through the 70s
when all those long-haired hippies were
sure that war was going to destroy the
world and uh and then the old people
were sure that the hippies would never
be
um good citizens who could keep the
country going and then you fast forward
and those same hippies are running
everything and doing a pretty good job
you know individually the the system's
got a lot of problems but you know we've
had how many crises since uh since I was
born you know we were running out of oil
but not really we were running out of
food but not really we were going to be
all nuking each other uh there was going
to be a hole in the ozone and it just on
and on and on so that the optimism that
I would give you is that humans are
insanely good at adapting if they can
see a problem coming
now the problem we're talking about I
think everybody sees so even if they
think the elections are good they can
certainly see that half of the country
is skeptical and they know that's a
problem by itself
so we can all see the problems and under
this condition where you can all see the
problems I even have a name for it it's
called The Adam's law of slow-moving
disasters if you can see it coming like
the year 2000 bug oh the year two we saw
it coming so even though we didn't have
much time it was enough the things that
really kneecap you are something like
covid because even though some people
saw it coming we weren't really ready in
the in the sense of really seeing it
coming
so I would say this is one of those we
can see it coming everybody's sure
there's a problem with the the election
at least credibility if not the vote
itself and we all know that we're
heading toward more problems not fewer
so I would expect
we'll probably do something like hitting
bottom
so one possibility is that the whatever
the aftermath of the next election is is
so bad
that we say all right we're finally
gonna fix the system so we're going to
do whatever we need to do which we
mostly know what to do
um
or or the other possibility which is
just as likely is that we will go on as
if nothing happened because
because uh have you ever tried to talk
to people who don't knew what we're
doing for a living yeah if you talk to a
normie lately like here's my general
conversation this is this is yesterday
actually yesterday with a with a living
human being an adult
so uh you know I got a story to tell you
about the Vivek ramaswamy who is a very
Grandma Swami is he's running for
president
what you've never heard of Vivek
ramaswamy
you don't even know he's running for
president
no well let me test this one
pergosian
pergosian Hannah the Wagner group
recently allegedly blew up in an
airplane
doesn't ring a bell that's that's every
conversation I've had and I was cited by
little politics bubble so if you take
that into the election
one percent of the country notices
that they're unhappy a bunch of people
on uh social media complain but they
always were complaining anyway
the the government just grinds on and
puts into office whoever they put into
office and you know we're worrying about
the economy again after that so it's
possible that nothing will happen no
matter what happens there just aren't
enough people who are involved counter
argument to that would be Scott that if
you ask those same normies about January
the 6th they're all going to know what
it was and have an opinion on it and
that you could argue is the product of
that very same system right
yes but let's say uh Joe Biden wins and
that very same system says everything
was fine the norm is going to say well
it looks like everything's fine you won
fair and square Trump was unpopular
that's the whole story and then we would
just go on
you know the the of course the
Republicans would complain bitterly but
they're doing that now there's not much
different you know what's happening
because of the complaints you know we
get we have something to talk about
that's it there's nothing physically
happening
hey KK do you like trigonometry of
course I do incredible interviews
fascinating guests phenomenal live shows
and hilarious raw streams in that case
you need to join our locals so you can
have access to even more brilliant
content that's right you get the chance
to win incredible prizes ask our
phenomenal guests your questions access
extra content and now the only place to
watch our Roars on catch up is on locals
our war shows still go out at 7pm UK
time 2 p.m Eastern as normal but if you
want to watch some after this time then
you're gonna need to sign up to our
locals Ross have now become too spicy to
stay on YouTube so they're only
available to watch back on our locals
page all you need to do to sign up is
click on the link below this video and
for just seven dollars a month you have
access to All of This brilliant content
seven dollars a month even for someone
of my persuasion that's a bargain see
fuel on locals
but surely there's a Tipping Point Scott
where
things go so mainstream with what's
happening the
it like I said eventually everybody will
know about it and the other counter
argument is
whilst I take your point everybody
everybody's becoming more political now
everybody is and certainly young people
well are they you know I'll tell you the
the feeling I get and the energy I I get
is this energy for uh you know a
national divorce and you know we'll
we'll pick up our weapons if something
goes wrong and yeah we're gonna have to
have a revolution physically in a tea
party and all that I don't feel any of
that energy in the real world when I
walk outside there's none of it so my my
assumption that there will be massive
political uh Grassroots like you know
massive problems almost zero there will
be political groups who will protest you
know organized groups have funding from
somebody and you know they got together
online but it's not going to represent
most people I mean it'd be you know the
the one percent acting out so I just
don't think there's going to be massive
civil unrest we'll just be more
complaining online mostly
well you're right I mean that sort of
national divorce thing having traveled
across America never heard one person I
was talking to political people it's a
very online conversation I think uh and
not necessarily a particularly useful
one uh however the the question I did
want to ask you is you said we mostly
know how to fix the election system so
that it's transparent and fair and and
seen to be both uh how do how do you do
that
well it might be fair that's the part I
don't know because it's unknowable
because there are elements of the
election system that are not transparent
by their nature for example wouldn't you
like to see the code of all the machines
and where that goes to and then the code
of how it's being counted and wouldn't
you like to see it before and after an
election yeah wouldn't you like to see
if anything changed since the last time
you looked at it I mean that would be a
basic thing or alternately you could do
what a lot of countries do don't use any
electronic stuff because by its nature
it's too hard to
um make it transparent because you can
always say but the thing you showed me
is that exactly what's in the machines
how do I know how do I know you didn't
send me like a fake thing or show me the
one machine that's not rigged or only a
few machines have to be rigged so it
doesn't matter how many you test you're
very unlikely you'd find a bad one so as
soon as you have anything electronic in
the system even if the company could
assure you that it's fair and even if
you were sure it was
you would never be able to prove it it
wouldn't have the transparency that you
need for this kind of this kind of level
of importance
so the first thing is do you even want
electronic machines the second thing is
the ballot boxes and the identifications
and the you know making sure that people
vote just once
take a simple idea somebody suggests
this I don't know if this is the idea
but if your ballot if your ballot drop
boxes uh had to be near an ATM
let's just say we made a law I'm just
you know spitballing here and
brainstorming but all of the ATMs have
cameras
so we would know if the same person
showed up 50 times that's one of the
claims uh that has never been
demonstrated to my satisfaction but you
know all we'd have to do is make sure
there's video on all of the dropboxes
now there might be some security issues
blah blah blah but I'm sure we could
work through them those are all legal
hurdles they could be unhurtled you
could take the hurdles away
so I'm no expert on the system but if I
said to you there has to be transparency
there have to be two people you know
from opposing sides watching every part
of the counting for example then then
that would get me a lot closer to at
least feeling we were serious about
transparency the the way things are now
is sends a very clear message that the
people in charge may be on both sides
don't want full of transparency that
that's the message I get as a a citizen
I don't see a lot of effort that looks
serious on the Republican side I don't
see it on the Democrat side they talk
about you know normal improvements of
things but nothing like what would give
us full transparency for example I don't
have any way to find that my vote got
recorded and successfully you know in
the final database is there really no
way to do that even for a sample group
of people for example couldn't you
couldn't you have a law this has some
randomly select a group of people will
be the only ones who have uh by opt-in
they can check their vote but nobody
knows who they are so then you can do a
random sample say okay did these ten
thousand people did they check and their
vote actually was recorded as they voted
or not you wouldn't have to check
everybody you could check ten thousand
randomly so there's probably a whole
bunch of things you could do that would
get you to full transparency but I don't
really see an effort anywhere well
that's really interesting and that's
exactly what I was going to ask you
while you were talking and you bring up
the point of not seeing the effort why
is that
it can only be because there's not
enough benefit to all the people at the
top my suspicion is
all right let me give you the worst case
suspicion
uh
every single one of our large entities
we've seen is corrupt you know from the
FBI to the doj and I'm not talking about
every person but at least leadership
elements we've seen that there our
Congress can be corrupt we've seen that
the CDC the basically everybody's
corrupt once you find out what's really
going on the exception we're told is all
50 separate elections for a national
election all 50 all 50 of them are all
good but everything else is corrupt
but not those 50 things so here's here's
my speculation pure speculation uh no
facts to back it up in some states
that's what we like Scott
that's a good basis of every Claim about
reality online which is just my
speculation yeah you're just honest
about it yeah so so my speculation is if
the Republicans are running some
elections they might be doing some
things that they don't want people to
see exactly in their states and maybe
the Democrats have some states that they
don't want you to see exactly what's
going on so my suspicion is that if
there's any uh impropriety it would be
at least a little bit spread across the
parties and both of them would say you
know what maybe we better not open this
box that's my best guess but it's just
speculation
it makes a lot of sense and Scott what
do you think it says about the system
that let's say Trump and Biden are the
two candidates what does that say about
the American system the political system
that these two men are your brightest
and best
well to put it in another way imagine
that the Democrats uh they elected the
least cognitive capable politician we've
ever seen except baby Federman and they
put him in the job that has the greatest
cognitive demand of maybe any job you
could even imagine the president of the
United States and the highest importance
and that's who they put in the job the
person who we can all see has the lowest
cognitive ability for any president so
far
now if that election is close let's say
with Trump or any anybody else and it
probably will be it'll be really close
does that not prove that our opinions
have been assigned to us as opposed to
we looked at the information and made up
our own mind I would say that if we have
a close election and Biden is one of the
candidates
and it still ends up razor razor close
that we've proven beyond a shadow of a
doubt that whatever you thought was
happening wasn't happening I.E informed
citizens making informed decisions that
are translated by the election system
into the accurate result whatever's
happening it isn't that and that's where
we're heading for so I guess we'll find
out
well what's happening there it seems to
me is tribalism and people will always
stick to tribe over reality well not
always but many people will but I think
the point that Francis was getting out
with you something I've I saw a graph on
on Twitter today
um which showed the average age of
politicians over the last two centuries
in the United States and you you can't
you can barely see the line because it's
close to Vertical right it's it's really
increased particularly in the last 60
years
um it's it and and it's it's bipartisan
by the way look at look at Mitch
McConnell there's another video of him
struggling to stay stand up straight and
talk at the same time this week has been
good bipartisan cooperation
and a string of uh
anything else you want to say I'm sure
let's go back to you
do you want to say anything else to the
Press
let's go back to you let's go ahead John
yeah you know and I worry that there's a
reason and this is the banker part of me
so I used to work for a bank for many
years before I was doing this kind of
stuff and when I worked for the bank
they had a rule that you couldn't take
uh was it four days off in a row or
three I forget but you couldn't take a
number of days off in a row
um uh or no you had to take that much
that's that's what it was you had to
take a vacation so the bank wouldn't let
you skip your vacations for too long and
the reason was that one of the ways that
people would rob the bank from the
inside you know in The Insider kind of
thing is they had to be there to cover
up things on a continuous basis so if
you made them stay away from the office
their crimes would would pop up because
somebody's covering for their job
so I wonder if it's a coincidence that
in a world where we don't trust anybody
to not be corrupt at the top anymore
that the old people can't retire because
then you'd find out what they were up to
imagine for example Joe Biden retires
just as we're finding out you know what
he might have been up to with Hunter by
if he stays president he can pardon
people and he can scare people away from
investigating if Mitch McConnell stays
in his position uh anybody who might
want to say look into his business is
not going to want to do it because it's
a political death sentence he's powerful
so when I see people who are way past
their expiration date and they stay in
sometimes it's because they don't want
to lose the majority but I worry that
it's the bank reason that is the moment
they were out of that job other people
could figure out what's been going on
all the time they were in there so that
that's that's my worry
go and it also says because something
quite profound which is everybody knows
that Joe Biden isn't in charge
he simply can't be no I mean he could be
but that's worse
yeah you know I mean he
you can't have a man like that in charge
of anything yeah it's hard to support
your opinion when uh when it does look
like he is in charge because things are
going so poorly like do you think that a
real person in charge would open the
Border
if an American if let's say there was an
American behind the scenes which
American behind the scenes would have
opened the border and let people from
other not even Central America you know
I think most of it at this point is
coming from other places in the world
that the cartels are recruiting from RFK
Jr did a great uh great piece on that
and who would do that only somebody who
was either cognitively declined you know
it you know just shot or somebody who's
working for China
you know it almost the if you look at
the list of things that are going wrong
or are sub-optable in the United States
it's almost a laundry list of what China
would want to happen to the United
States I'll take the simplest one
tick tock
how in the world how in the world is
that still legal in the United States
when China doesn't even allow it in
China you know and you know the the
arguments on both sides they they argue
that data security instead of the
influence problem which is by far the
bigger problem and it's almost as if
they're not trying or there's nobody
American in charge
there's something going on either our
intelligence people need it so they can
spy on people which might be the answer
it might be the intelligence people in
the United States are finding Tick Tock
so useful that you know they're they're
willing to put up with whatever danger
has the other possibility is that just
China has too much control of the United
States and you know I saw Fox News
running ads for tick tock the other day
what you know so so I thought at one
point I thought there's something that
Democrats want because it helps them get
elected
and then it seemed like the people on
the right were you know properly
noticing the danger
but then I see the Fox News is taking
advertising from them
so I mean there's something else going
on
okay let me push back on that Scott
because I get what you're saying I get
your point
but I think your discounting ideology as
well what happens if you are a far left
progressives and you think borders are a
symbol of white supremacy every no human
being is illegal
there will be those people in the
Democrat Party I will bear every penny
that is in my bank account which isn't
much but that is true surely
well you know even Biden was opposed to
opening borders
so you know if this were just Joe Biden
the The Joe Biden we've always known
probably the Border would be closer to
closed I mean he might he might be you
know accepting a few more uh types of
people or something like that but I
think it would be a lot more closed if
he were actually making the decisions we
have a pretty long history of what he's
thought about border security and it'd
be weird if it changed at this age so it
does suggest that
um something else or somebody else is in
charge yes but in terms of let me let me
answer your question I feel like I
dodged your question so let me ask that
tribalism
is always going to describe 80 percent
of it
but but things change because the you
know the few fluid people in between so
I'll accept tribalism as 80 to 90
percent of it easily but the other 10 is
where all the action happens
yeah that's a good point it's an
interesting point about Tick Tock
because a kind of semi-joke response
would be to say well this is what
happens when you get a bunch of 80 year
olds running things they have no idea
what's going on on kids phones but it's
a it's a try point in that I think
you're right that that is a strange
thing and but but the thing is it's not
just happening in America I mean here in
the UK it's the same we don't even have
a conversation about banning Tick Tock
and
um it's it just seems like Western
political Elites just have dropped the
ball on so many different issues
yeah and the things that we decide are
important uh is is really it's hard to
justify them in terms of their actual
importance in the real world I mean
everything seems to be if somebody's
funding somebody who's a good Advocate
then we act like that's the most
important person thing in the world
because it made a lot of noise so I I
think noise is what we're responding to
Scott do you think part of the problem
is as well is that anyone can see the
United States is going through severe
economic difficulties and the money that
comes in from China is much needed if
not arguably essential hence even for
someone for folks news you know which is
hemorrhaging viewers it's hemorrhaging
relevancy it's hemorrhaging money it
needs those Tick Tock ads in order to
help it stay afloat
yeah a lot of it is pure economics I I
agree that you know follow the money
um it just always works even when you're
sure it shouldn't which is the weird
thing about it you know if you're
talking about it why why a priest did
something you like to think it's not for
money but then if you check it's like
well coincidentally that did seem to you
know help the money thing too so
money money is most of the explanation
for most things it even explains
tribalism I mean ultimately people are
looking for their financial benefit and
that's why they they they separate in
tribes
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy DNS is a company for you easy DNS
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be canceled culture D
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy DNS have
Rock Solid Network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that move your
domains and websites over to easy DNS
right now all you've got to do is go to
easydns.com forward slash triggered
that's easydns.com forward slash
triggered use our promo code which is
also triggered and get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
and I was wondering uh if we can go and
talk about those people that normies
haven't heard of the vivex and Nikki
Haley's and all of the of those people
and RFK Juniors of the world uh what do
you make of all the other potential
candidates do they think any of them
have any chance uh on the Republican
side of uh getting close to being
nominated if things go really well for
them uh and likewise on the Democrats is
anyone going to amount any challenge to
Joe Biden of any note
let me let me give you some optimism
first and I'll tell you the bad news the
optimism is uh I've never seen a better
uh slate of candidates I'm I'm just
blown away by the quality of the let's
say the undercard you know people like
Vivek he's changing he's changing
politics just by running he's changing
the arguments if you if you've heard him
talk about climate change I just I just
saw him slay a couple of people who were
triggered triggered into cognitive
distance because he's the first person
who can explain it well it is his point
of view the climate change agenda is a
hoax is what I said and what I mean by
that is that the temperature related or
climate-related disaster death rate
tornadoes hurricanes Heat Wave fires the
number of deaths over the last 100 years
is down by 98 for every hundred people
that died of a climate related disaster
in 1920 that number is two people today
that fact is not disputed the reason why
is more abundant and plentiful access to
fossil fuels more people die today still
eight times as many more people die of
cold temperatures rather than warm ones
the right answer to all temperature
related deaths is more abundant access
to fossil fuels the Earth is covered by
more green surface area coverage today
than it was half a century or a century
ago because carbon dioxide is plant food
so there these are the these are hard
facts not disputed but that you don't
hear from the climate agenda
wouldn't the the reduction in deaths be
more related to technology that's
allowed us to to warn people and to get
people out of the way of danger and
there's nothing to do with possibility
covered by fossil fuels technology
powered by fossil fuels and that's my
point so I ever adaptation I favor
climate Mastery look at the likes of
what Bjorn Lumberg to Alex Epstein even
Steve coonan a physicist who served in
the Obama Administration I've read all
their books cover to cover I think the
reality is the climate change policies
are going to be more hostile to human
flourishing than actual threats posed by
climate change itself
other people have taken the same
approach but he explains it in a way
that that the people understand it for
the first time and you're watching heads
explode as they try to wrap their head
around the fact and the main the main
thing he's adding is adding that there's
a cost and there's a benefit which is so
trivial and yeah but yeah I was like
what's what's the show uh with Harvey
Levitt in there uh so he was he was
talking to him and his co-host and you
watch people who are on one side and
they're focusing on the warming but what
about the humans are making the warming
and he'll say yes that's true and and
that's that's good technique except the
part that uh they're arguing and then
say but you're forgetting that cold
kills more people if you were to net it
all we're better off with fossil fuels
would be his argument now when you look
at the net argument it's just a killer
argument it just crushes the other side
but the argument before Vivek was more
like it's getting warm no it's not
no seriously we got all the science I
don't believe it so that's not a good
argument but Vivek goes in accepting all
science and then completely
reinterpreting and yeah reframing the
argumental as a killer so even if
tomorrow he got out of the race
what he left us even today today he did
it and now it's recorded you're seeing
the quality of the argument about
climate change so improved that it
probably will change the actual
um policies because it's just a killer
explanation RFK Jr his explanation about
uh various drugs and vaccinations not
being tested in at the level that you
thought they were is a huge huge
um
piece of information that the public
wasn't aware of and even though he's
getting pilloried for you know a hundred
different things that what he's bringing
to the conversation about chronic
illnesses and even our food supply is
not as healthy as they should be huge
huge benefit you look at Larry Elder
talking about uh
um the kids who don't have two parents
huge benefit so this is the first time
I've ever seen the the undercard if you
will bring such immediate real benefits
without getting elected I've never seen
anything like that so short of that and
I think DeSantis is solid he's just
boring
so so there are at least four candidates
who even without agreeing with every
piece of their positions I could say I
would be happy with that person as
president and RFK Jr on the Democrat
side so it's not even about party but
you know Biden of course is not even
political he's just not there so you
don't know who's running things so uh I
don't know if I answered the question
because I went off on my own tangent
there well I think you gave us the good
news that there's lots of potentially
good candidates the bad news I imagine
is none of them are going to be
president
well so uh on the on the right it only
depends if Trump is still eligible and
Alive you know uh Tucker Carlson
suggested by a video I think yesterday
that the pattern of things suggests that
the
um somebody on the left will actually
try to assassinate Trump
now I don't know if that's true but his
argument for it is that we do do things
that bad you know it wouldn't be outside
of the realm of something the United
States has ever done and if you look at
the level of the coordinated actions
against him you know the all the hoaxes
ETC and the fact that they're
desperately trying to put him in jail
over things that most experts say would
not be jailable
um
it I would say you can't rule anything
out
so you know Vivek or uh DeSantis might
have a real shot but only in the worst
case scenario where something happens to
Trump now as far as Biden uh I think the
smart money says he won't make it to the
even even the election day
um in my opinion he's already been told
that he's done
I think that's what his long vacations
were about I think that was so that he
and Jill could sort of absorb the you're
quitting what are you going to do about
it how do you feel about it uh because I
think it's hard to tell somebody that
they're done at that level I mean that
would be the hardest conversation
anybody ever had and
so so I think uh we're waiting for the
Democrats to figure out their own
problem babies slip in slip in Governor
Newsom or something but uh I don't think
anybody thinks Biden is really going to
be alive and functioning by election day
2024.
that's an interesting point you said
something which I find incredibly
interesting but is also to me a very
real symptom of the problem that we find
ourselves in is that you said and look I
agree DeSantis he's solid but boring
what's wrong with being solid and boring
isn't somebody who you want to run stuff
shouldn't they be solid and boring
yeah you know what if if you could get
rid of the whole campaign problem where
you have to win an election you know if
you could just assign them I would be so
happy that we had a reasoned adult
running the country even if I don't
agree with everything he does that's a
whole separate question but at least you
know wouldn't you like by the way I've
said this about Vivek wouldn't you love
to know if there's an international uh
event you know the G whatevers that that
your guy the guy representing your
country is the smartest one in the room
for once for once
like wouldn't you like to know that no
matter what else happens that you sent
the smartest guy and everybody else was
oh God this guy's the smartest guy in
the room now DeSantis is super capable I
think he's you know also very smart uh
so we have some good options if if we
could find a way to put them in office
and like I said RFK Jr would be such a
wild card that even with Democrat
policies uh that not everybody's Gonna
Love he's a serious person and I think
he has the right uh mental state about
helping the country I'd be comfortable
with him
but they're never going to let him get
anywhere near that are they
does it look like it no it doesn't
no because I mean the Democrats I mean
if they look at what they did with
Bernie you know they and they they want
their guy in Power that's what made
Trump so unique is that he clearly
wasn't their guy that was what was so
invigorating about him
yeah
um we don't really know how things
really run behind the curtain but you
know if you're just judging from the few
things you can see it does look like
somebody else is in charge
and that somebody else has very specific
ideas about who should be in charge and
if you look at the the totality of the
coordinated actions it has every sign of
somebody trying to cover up their own
crimes
as in whoever's really in charge doesn't
want anybody investigating them either
so I feel like it's called what do you
mean what what signs what what uh what
crimes what are you talking about
well whoever went back to Biden is doing
it out of desperation not because they
think it's a good idea so who who acts
out of desperation if you say well it's
the team thing they just they want their
team to win but this feels way beyond
that
team win would be Gavin Newsom already
already running
now what I think they want is they well
in 2020 they wanted a guy
who could unite because she was so kind
of middle and Bland who could unite the
Democrats and not offend the demo any
Democratic voters so that Trump lost
that's what they wanted right well that
was a story but don't you think they
could have found a hundred Bland people
to do that I mean bland is pretty easy
to find what they found he was vice
president he had name recognition you
know all right all right but we've been
in the game a long time as well but
considering the alternative explanation
he was the most connected to Obama and
sort of the Hillary Clinton part of the
machine that's the part of the machine
that seems to be in charge I don't know
what individuals but it seems like that
that Universe the people seem to be in
charge do you think they want somebody
who's not their guy
to be in that office they need their
guide to be in the office because that's
how they stay in charge well it was also
how they avoid any investigations into
anything they may have done so it feels
like not an election to find your your
best guy or woman it doesn't feel like
an election that's just team it it
screams two sides trying to stay on a
jail I mean honestly the only way I
think Trump stays out of jail is by
winning the election
you know you might you might literally
have to Pardon himself which I'd be fine
with
um and I think Biden might have to
Pardon himself and haunt her or at least
Hunter before he leaves so to me the
entire thing looks like Joe may be
trying to hold on to keep Hunter out of
jail you know to maintain his his pardon
ability but without pardoning him too
soon because then it affects the
election right so if if Joe I'm a pure
speculation I can't read minds but if
you put me in his situation if you say
all right you're Joe Biden what do you
do the first thing I do is make sure I
get to the second election get elected
and then I can pardon anybody I want
because I'm not running for election
then
so he might be limping to the you know
the Finish Line just to make sure Hunter
doesn't go to jail now that might be
everything we're seeing like it might
explain all observations a father trying
to keep his son out of jail because
that's going to Trump everything you
know no pun intended you know that's
going to be bigger than money it's going
to be bigger than winning it's going to
be bigger than team it's going to be
bigger than everything so and and is
there any way to keep Hunter out of
trouble unless Biden's in office
I don't see the second way
because I think he would be instantly
unprotected if Biden left office I
suppose if Biden left office and
likewise with Trump I don't if you feel
that the prosecution and indictment of
Donald Trump is political I wonder if he
had said in 2020 you know what the
election was stolen but I I'm done I'm
gonna go back to running my business and
enjoy my retirement I don't think they
would be coming after him and the
argument would be likewise with the
bidens
maybe maybe if they leave people would
leave them alone because what's there to
be gained by persecuting or Prosecuting
them I don't think that Trump's
complaining about the election itself
has much of anything to do with how
anybody feels about him
because that's just Trump yeah what what
is what is he ever you know not given
you his best impression of you know his
view of things the election is just more
the same he's just Trump being Trump
um so to imagine that that's you know
his election problems were behind that's
not that it's about Trump they just
can't have him in office I don't think
he has anything to do with complaints
about the election because if he said
I'm not running again don't you think
they'd leave him alone
probably
so this is what I'm saying if if Joe
Biden said I'm leaving you know Kamala
takeover or Gavin Newsom or whoever it
might be wouldn't they wouldn't that be
the best strategy to protect him and his
son from prosecution
no there's nothing better than pardon
ability because the the pardon's
absolute the other is a bet
yes it's true
Scott I mean what you're describing is
essentially the greatest soap opera ever
written you know I mean why watch The
Bold and the Beautiful or any of these
other ones when you can watch this well
that speaks to elon's point about
reality being the most entertaining
version of itself right no exactly
number so go for it and then I've got a
follow-on question so here's something
that the Casual Observer of news never
really understands that news about
public figures is never true
yeah now let me test that with you
you've probably been the subject of news
stories because you're doing so well
right it did those new stories
accurately capture the the context of
your situation whatever it was
not guilty on all charges thank you
Scott
no and and by the way we should say as
well uh that old media and New Media
both will spread complete lies and
misinformation about you with no
hesitation right so the Casual viewer of
news thinks oh if it's in the National
Enquirer maybe I don't trust her so much
but even that doesn't work anymore
because there is likely to be right as
anybody else
um but if you're a subject of the news
as I am you know even if you're an
international headline for a few weeks
as sometimes I am uh I'm the only one
who knows that the stories are false or
not not false in terms of what they
reported that might be exactly true but
the context would reverse how you felt
about it if you knew the context which
you know most people will never know
context of anything so what's really
going on with the government I don't
know it might be tribal it might be
money it might be somebody staying out
of jail it might be ego there are 50
into things it could be but the only
thing I'm sure of is that whatever the
public thinks is happening it's not that
one
the only thing I know from experience
because when you talk about politics and
you reach a certain level of let's say
notoriety
people who are behind the curtain all
the time they start telling you what's
back there so you hear a version of the
world that is so different from what the
general public thinks is just base
reality that you can never see a new
news story as real again I just see oh
who ran this up which billionaire was
behind that that's all I see now but the
average consumer says well I'll bet 80
of this stuff is true
no it doesn't
and
watching what is happening in America as
we all are as the entire world is
I mean this is a disaster for America
this this Sideshow the Trump indictments
the the Biden you know gambling his way
through you know speeches falling asleep
in various dinners I mean the Chinese
and the Russians must be looking at this
going
I mean they could they've completely
screwed it up
well let me say a few things about that
it could be a social media and news
effect that we think things are worse
than they've ever been
because I'm pretty sure that we you know
our government probably was never
staffed with a bunch of honest people uh
if you look at it and say if you look at
the stories of like the the times uh
Abraham Lincoln's time you know Honest
Abe he wasn't so honest I I don't want
to be a spoiler but not so honest and
you know I'm pretty sure that
um our ability to talk about every
little thing that happens and uh just
the general tribal nature of social
media makes everything look like an
emergency uh here here would be the
Counterpoint to that apparently the
government works no matter who's in
charge
and you know you could argue as the
pro-biden people have that the Biden
Administration has accomplished some
substantial things
you know you could argue you didn't want
them accomplished by Yo infrastructure
Bill blah blah blah and there are things
that happen and there might be some
productive things happening with Iran
don't know yet too early but maybe we've
seen that manufacturing is being moved
back from China Trump would have done
the same thing and it looks like it's
actually happening and I would give the
administration credit for that so
there's a whole bunch of things that
seem to happen
competently no matter who's in charge
because you know it's the it's the
people below them they're doing the real
work
so we might be able to just skate
through and competently like we always
have
um but on the other hand you know you
never know when there's going to be a
revolution I just don't feel the energy
for that right now yeah that makes sense
well on that a somewhat optimistic and
happy notes you mentioned uh being a
headline for a few weeks I didn't want
to ask you about that so we'll ask you
about that when we head over to locals
uh but before we do that we always end
on the same question which is what's the
one thing we're not talking about that
you think we really should be
you know people tell me I talk about
this too much but it's the nature of
reality itself
and one of my predictions the weirdest
one back in 2016 I think
um I said in public that Trump would
change more than politics he would
change our understanding of reality
itself
and that has happened we we're
completely uh on moored from what is
real and what is fake because we Now
understand that the news and social
media were narrative drivers not fact
drivers so pretty much everybody
understands at this point the things you
see in the news should not be trusted as
true
things that all the experts tell us
should not be regarded as true because
the pandemic taught us that experts
could be bought even all of them so they
you take that learning back to climate
change and you're 97 of scientists in
the same page doesn't that look
different now after you go through the
pandemic 97 of scientists on the same
side huh that doesn't mean anything
anymore that used to mean a lot it
actually means literally nothing once
you see that how easy it is to co-opt
all of the scientists since the same
time so I think the nature of reality
and I think we are a simulation
I believe that there are probably lots
of simulations out there and that we
were created by some intelligent species
that might have looked like us
um and we're avatars in that creation so
that to me explains everything we
observe
it's a longer conversation but you asked
well should we talk more about that's it
but people there we go well yeah uh
Scott thank you very much uh obviously
we recommend everybody check out not
only your latest book but uh you have
several uh there you go so reframe your
brain uh and head on over to locals
where we ask Scott your questions and
also we'll talk about uh is it fair to
say it was a self-cancellation score or
was it self-inflicted or just a
cancellation or what what would be the
right way to talk about it uh I like I
like to call myself disgraced
I just like the way it sounds
um this Grace cartoonist well we'll talk
about how how you became disgraced on
locals yeah yeah let's just say I put
myself in a situation where uh
cancellation was likely and I was aware
of it
perfect well head on over to locals and
we'll see you there
you mentioned being labeled as a racist
it'd be helpful I think for people who
didn't follow closely would have
happened for you to give us a it may be
a quick summary of what you said why you
said it and then address yeah the The
quick summary would get me in more
trouble than uh than not saying at all
thank you
foreign
[Music]